so here's my vision it just came to me
picture the border
we build a wall
[Applause]
we build a tall big a beautiful wall
and we have the wall goes to mile
yeah it's a shame you didn't build that
wall around the nursing homes you freak
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
happy happy wednesday favorite day of
the week
oh i know why and i'm not biting okay
to the monologue capitol hill made them
ill
according to vice news which apparently
still exists
folks in the media are struggling with
post-traumatic stress disorder
caused by the january 6th breach of the
capital
in fact some reporters won't even return
to the building and others are in
therapy
one longtime reporter meaning he's old
had to retire
soon after the attack and others can't
sleep
maybe they've seen their ratings one
bloomberg news reporter named eric
wassen claims
he feels unsafe in his house which is
weird because he lives in dc where
people feel unsafe
when they leave their house apparently
seeing a clown in a viking hat knocking
over a bottle of whiteout on dick
durbin's desk is tantamount to being
mauled by isis in your kitchen
they're more distraught than the
kardashians during a silicon shortage
[Laughter]
thank god we haven't had a war on our
soil yet how would they be able to cover
it there'd be a run on scented candles
and dream journals
but can you blame these poor souls i
mean when you hear about january 6th
you're convinced it's worse than 9 11
perhaps
it is but to them
to me though there was less loss of life
on january 6th
january 6 was worse than 9 11 because
it's continued
to rip our country apart and give
permission for people
to pursue autocratic means and so i
think we're at a much worse place than
we've been and as i've said i think to
you before i think we're in the most
perilous point
in time since 1861 in the advent of the
civil war
he's just bad crazy
[Laughter]
so yeah to him it was worse than 911.
tell it to the families
of the 9 11 first responders
sorry but that's our media they've never
been good at priorities a group of
largely unarmed housewives and dads walk
into the capitol and that's somehow
worse than three planes flying into
buildings killing thousands
now i condemn what happened on january
6. early on i said when barbarians are
at the gate
the republicans have to be the gates not
the barbarians
that day they weren't but the media is
beating the story to death like it's a
teenager caught shoplifting in tehran
because it's a nice distraction from the
horrible
they caused over the past decade the
crime the violence the poisoned
education system
january 6 is their shield from blame
i wonder what the angry white male
thinks
hey guys one more time sure why not
this is me this is my brain
this is the media this
is me watching stories that the media
does about themselves
any questions come on you got some
questions don't you
i'll take questions
he never takes questions but i wonder
what the angry black male thinks
go to sleep
the best advice the best advice if you
can't sleep
so i wonder wondering did any of these
reporters experience
any psychological trauma during the
riots of last year
i mean other than having to read or
watch their own work
but you know who did suffer truly the
victims of the riots the people who
owned stores and homes that burned to
the ground
but the media seemed a little detached
from all that who can forget this
delightful moment
so i i want to be clear in how i
characterize this this is a
mostly protest uh it is not
uh it is not generally speaking unruly
the fires have been started and
there's a crowd that is relishing that
[Laughter]
it's just too easy the crowds weren't
the only ones relishing it
meanwhile the crime sprees that followed
were denied by deceptive adults like don
lemon and joy reid they deny the crime
because they or their imaginary friends
didn't experience it firsthand
what a great journalism gig just report
on what personally happens to you then
you never have to do
anything so why the hysteria over
january 6
as opposed to the ongoing violence in
portland atlanta san francisco
l.a new york seattle well the crime
spikes couldn't be used politically
because of the racial component
but the january 6 mob was wider than a
dave matthews fan making snow angels
and that is white so uh they try to tie
it to a phantom white supremacy movement
but let's take a look at this guy from
january 6th
does that guy look like an emblem of
white supremacy
that's not even blackface but look at
him it
seems like the opposite of supremacy
and he's been in jail for six months
that's way longer than the looters and
arsonists who caused billions in damages
gee i wonder if shopkeepers feel safe in
their homes knowing that this flake is
locked up
no actors or politicians bothered to
bail him out and he didn't even set fire
to anything
maybe his worst crime was scaring nancy
pelosi
but then her eyebrows always look like
that
clearly the guy's unwell as sick as
matthew dowd
but no one cares he's no political hero
he won't be on
msnbc spewing nonsense about 911 but not
only does the media not care about these
suspects they actually salute rounding
them all up
so the media creates a narrative that
it's a deadly insurrection caused by the
big lie
but the big lie was actually their four
years pushing of the russian collusion
delusion
and when an unarmed protester gets
killed well that's par for the course
imagine though if it were a blm
protester and not a trumper
holy crap so it's not surprising to see
how the media plays this
squeezing as much juice out of one event
while ignoring a crime wave
it's because the rise in crime
implicates the media and the dems
so they can't talk about it they spent a
year denying it some even
laughed it off again yeah democratic
cities are
in chaos right now is this what you want
from joe biden and they're going to take
your country away and they're taking
down the statues and
crime is rising oh my gosh it's so
bad and they get defunding police it's
like
the only time this idiot was right about
something and he was being sarcastic
by the way i wonder if i if they get a
royalty every time i play that uh
segment at this rate don can finally buy
his calf implants
fact is the media are the most
egocentric fools on the planet
only they could say they're traumatized
by one day in january where an
unarmed protester died as they ignore
the victims of crime around them right
now
every day but if they didn't see it then
it didn't happen
especially if it happened to you
[Applause]
tonight yes
he's crushed more rolls than joey
chestnut at a hot dog eating contest
after daniel roba
he started three new companies in the
time it took me to read this
author of the great new book woke inc
the best
ramaswamy
she has a heart of gold which she's
shoplifted from macy's
fox news contributor catch him
and all you can eat buffets have tyrus
insurance
my massive sidekick and host of enough
said
on fox nation
[Applause]
dan welcome to the haven't seen you in a
while nice to see you thank you so much
uh anybody doesn't know who dan is he is
the pride of allentown oh thank you
yes they have the holy eye valley yes
that is true that is true right now
there are about 100 people going yes
yes okay so do you think this comparison
makes sense 9 11 to january 6th
i well i do think it is a bit of an
insult too
to many people who yeah who who perished
i mean i it's i
look if somebody has ptsd
okay let's talk about that but you know
let's not
when we start saying i have ptsd because
you know i
there was a goose yes walked in front of
my car
i think i think that you know we there's
there's people who really suffer from
this there's people
who suffer from rape and all these
terrible things and they have it
and it is real yes but is this real i
don't it disturbs me but the thing is if
you
get ptsd from a goose you can make the
goose your therapy animal
you could do that and take it on the
plane yeah yeah you could do all that
that solves two problems right right
right it's a good point it is yeah i've
always been okay with geese i don't know
why i picked on ghee
i don't know why either i know i know it
seems like they're horrible
geese are terrible terrible creatures
though but swans are worse
swansea they they look pretty but they
have a vehicle use their necks to
strangle other birds
is that true i made it up
they ate it up but i've learned that if
i say things with force people will
believe me
worked on me yes vivek you are filthy
rich you're like a zillionaire
aren't you i'm like dirty dirty rich
you're dirty not quite filthy
yes yes yes by the way i'm excited about
your book your book is
is going to be it's all about how social
justice
wokism has infiltrated corporations and
they're using it as a shield against
their
nefarious behavior am i right you're
dead on right i mean look
my parents had an arranged marriage
right people put them together who
knew them they met each other within a
week they were married that was a good
arranged marriage
that's the one that worked the book is
about an arranged marriage
gone awry it's more like mutual
prostitution where you have the woke
left
and big business neither of whom really
loves one another they actually look
down on one another
but they got married anyway because each
was able to do what the other couldn't
alone
and after occupying just describing
normal marriage
that's not an arranged marriage we
actually jump into that thing
on purpose try not to get myself in
trouble tonight but uh
what do you make of this uh the how the
media looks at these two
instances of rampant crime in one day
of uh of a mob yeah i mean look i think
that this is
this is classic media hypocrisy but i do
think if there was one point in there
that i want to take as
a valid point i don't think it's what he
meant but it's the reaction
to what happened after january 6th
actually frightens me
more right in the reaction after 9 11
because after 9 11 and i speak as a
person with civil libertarian instincts
okay i didn't like what the
military-industrial complex did in this
country
creating a surveillance state that has
haunted us for 20 years now to the
20-year anniversary
taking our shoes off but that's the
military-industrial complex yeah
that is not as bad greg in my mind as
the woke industrial complex which
involves private companies now
constitutionally unconstrained because
as bad as the military industrial
complex was in post-9 11 days
at least it was constrained by this
pesky thing called the constitution
where now these guys in government are
able to give their dirty work
to the private sector and say hey oh
those are just guys on the west coast
acting as private companies isn't that
what your republicans want that's more
dangerous
exactly exactly it's like oh
you know what they're the bad guys and
they're private industries so they can
do whatever they want
tyrus how you doing i'm phenomenal greg
yes
and by the way i applaud your dirty rich
because i'm hood rich so
that's all it's like i'd rather be dirty
rich than john rich
he's a friend of yours that gives you
free whispers the amount of times that
man has gotten you drunk
brought you boots yeah but i always wake
up naked
mother loves you and this is how you
treat him
damn you greg gutfeld yes but speaking
of damn you
damn this is can we just call this what
this is
yeah there's nothing how many reporters
were held hostage in january 6th
yeah none if mike pence is okay isn't he
yes pence they were literally calling
they were going to come get him yeah
the noose was for pence and he's doing
stand-up now he's doing fine
he's got chuckles up in west haven
podcast
yeah make sure you tipped away but the
point is january 6 was bad and here's
the awesome thing
the fbi caught the bad guys they're all
going to jail and now they're going to
catch more because they got more footage
that's kind of solved we really don't
need a panel of that we don't
they every time the senate and we're
going to get a committee together why
you had a committee with russia and you
came back with well yeah
could be could be not i could have done
that i mean they had a committee for
you know for for kennedy because they
had one guy's
home movie that lasted 14 seconds yeah
yeah
like we need more information about this
we have too much
yeah here they're like well run run
those four we have four million cameras
run that yeah we know who everybody is
yeah they're still hoping
for that that pipe bomb that somehow
will implicate president trump you've
literally tried
everything the fbi didn't question him
because it wasn't about him they knew
who did it who planned it
and they've arrested them what happened
to the pipe bombs that's a great
question
there was there were they got them ahead
of time or they found them or whatever
but the the point is
that middle that mystery is solved we
didn't have to go look for who did it we
have it on film who did it yeah they
literally dressed up
in ridiculous outfits they were pretty
easy to
spot at denny's yeah they weren't you
know what they were the
cat they were the opposite of antifa
yeah
antifa spent all their time trying to
hide their faces while they hurt people
these guys were showing off who they
were because they thought they were
trying to
they weren't trying to change the
constitution they thought they were
trying to save it
they were wrong and obvi right obviously
i've condemned it you've condemned it
we've all condemned it so many times but
yet in these interviews you're saying
there's been no accountability
i haven't heard anyone who has really
failed to condemn it that i know
and also as you mentioned tyrus 400
people in from 40 different states have
been arrested
already so i think that going to jail is
accountability
yes i think it is accountability and in
general
i just think it's bad to compare
anything to 9 11.
like it's just bad form i'm not going to
say it's like because you
said not to do that yeah that is true i
always find that you always say
analogies are a problem because they're
never one to one oh no it's gonna be
space between that thing and that other
thing okay we gotta move on because we
got so much more
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else